[Music]
the spirit of the revealed religion has
not yet surmounted its Consciousness as
such or what is the same it's actual
self-consciousness is not the object of
its Consciousness Spirit itself is a
whole in the self-differentiated moments
within it fall within the sphere of
picture thinking and in the form of
objectivity the content of this picture
thinking is absolute spirit and all that
now remains to be done is to supersede
this mere form or rather since this
belongs to Consciousness as such its
truth must already have yielded itself
in the shape of Consciousness this
surmounting of the object of
Consciousness is not to be taken
one-sidedly to mean that the object
showed itself as returning into the self
but is to be taken more specifically to
mean not only that the object as such
presented itself to the self as
Vanishing but rather that it is the
externalization of self-consciousness
that deposits the thing hood of the
object and that this externalization has
not merely a negative but a positive
meaning a meaning which is not only for
us or in itself but for
self-consciousness itself
the negative of the object or its
self-supercession has a positive meaning
for self-consciousness that is
self-consciousness knows the nothingness
of the object on the one hand because it
externalizes its own self
for in this externalization it posits
itself as object or the object as itself
in virtue of the indivisible Unity of
being for self
on the other hand this positing at the
same time contains the other moment that
is that self-consciousness has equally
superseded this externalization and
objectivity too and taking it back into
itself so that it is in communion with
itself in its otherness as such this is
the movement of Consciousness and in
that movement Consciousness is the
totality of its moments equally
Consciousness must have related itself
to the object in accordance with the
totality of the latter's determinations
and have thus grasped it from the
standpoint of each of them this totality
of its determinations establishes the
object as an implicitly spiritual being
and it does truly become a spiritual
being for Consciousness when each of its
individual determinations is grasped as
a determination of the self or through
the spiritual relationship to them that
was just mentioned
with paragraph
788 we now finally make our way into the
final section of the phenomenology of
spirit called absolute knowing and the
absolute will get discussed an awful lot
in this and you might say well why does
this culminate in knowing or knowledge
and why all this talk so much about
Consciousness and
self-consciousness well for Hegel you
know philosophy is indeed tied up with
the Practical tied up with the world
we're going to see this already a
reference to you know not the vehicle
kite as such but the the vehicle actual
self-consciousness self-consciousness
that exists in this world in a temporal
sense but what we really are aiming at
is something speculative something
theoretical in the sense of activity
that contemplates that understands that
makes sense of things the resting in
place if you like and this is you know
kind of in touch with an older attitude
towards the relationship between the
speculative and the Practical we see so
many ancient and medieval thinkers you
know prioritizing the higher level of
philosophy not just concerned with human
Affairs but also understanding this in
terms of resting in its object at last
no longer being caught up in a Restless
process and this can be quite active you
know Aristotle's reference which Hegel
picked up way way earlier in the
phenomenology to thought thinking itself
it's not a completely inactive thing but
it's active in a different way and
that's sort of where we're moving to
it's interesting to note too if you
compare this to the beginning of the
religion section or the beginning of
some of the other sections you know
reason Spirit we wind up at some sort of
end point within the previous uh very
complicated dialectic that has developed
so you know Consciousness and
self-consciousness feed into reason
reasons long long you know uh discursis
and and digressions and dialectics lead
into spirit and then spirit is by far
even a longer section A Lot happens in
there eventually we get to the
enlightenment freedom and the terror all
this stuff about morality conscience and
the Beautiful Soul of course and then it
feeds into religion and we begin with
you could say a new problematic but not
one that's absolutely out of the blue
one that is in part referencing what
happened earlier and we're going to see
two different things going on in this
paragraph that are kind of similar to
what's going on in the first paragraphs
of religion so we have a reference to
the previous stage the previous Shape Of
Consciousness in this case revealed
religion the culmination of the large
religion section where we began with
natural religion and then religion in
the form of Art and then revealed
religion right so there's a singular
Focus you might say a cumulative Focus
and then as we're going to see a little
bit later on there's this whole
reference back well actually first to a
kind of generic sense of this to
gestaltin forms of Consciousness and
then at the end of this he's going to
say that uh we've got a movement of
Consciousness which we're going to talk
about in a bit in that movement
Consciousness is the totality
of its moments and so it relates itself
to the object in accordance with the
totality of the object's determinations
and it grasps them or grasps it the the
object from the standpoint of each of
them well what does that mean well you
know hegelian philosophy is devoted to
looking at things that are complex in
their complexity in their totality as
he's calling it here and so with each of
those shapes of Consciousness as we're
going to see in the next couple
paragraphs you know very explicit
references to particular shapes of
Consciousness he's going to say uh that
we've got you know a totality of
determinations establishing the object
as an implicitly spiritual being and
that each of the individual
determinations is grasped as a
determination of the self and what is
that well that's all the previous shapes
of Consciousness that we have worked our
way through they're still out there in
the world so to speak these and this you
know brings up a very important question
that we can raise for Hegel and hegeline
as well you know is it we just move like
from uh stage to Stage progress happens
and then we leave behind pretty much all
of the stuff except what is Afghan what
is sublated or transcended while
incorporating in terms of its idea or
what matters to it well that's one
interpretation right you get this like
linear history first this and this and
this and this and we you know move in a
nice progression that you can chart out
but the world is way more complicated
than that
the previous
shapes of Consciousness still occur
right that's part of why the
phenomenology despite the fact of Hegel
being wrong that history ended a whole
other topic to talk about can prove
useful for people in the present we can
be like you know we see something
happening and then we're like wow this
looks an awful lot like I'm just
grabbing something at random here a
paragraph 482 where it talks about the
lord of the world becoming conscious of
what they are the universal power of the
actual world the destructive power they
exercise against the self of their
subjects the self which stands against
them his power is not the union and
Harmony of spirit in which persons would
recognize their own self-consciousness
and we can look at that and we can say
holy crap that's happening right here
this is happening politically this is
happening in terms of the CEO of this
multinational corporation this is
happening in this educational
institution this is happening and we
could go down the line couldn't we so
it's not as if everything is completely
superseded and gone away and that is
kind of like what happened in the
religion section when we saw that Hegel
said hey these four previous
developments the Consciousness section
the self-consciousness section you're
like how the hell does this follow from
what happened in force and the
understanding the reason section in the
spirit section are all brought together
into the knot that is religion and while
we're doing that now with absolute
knowing
so that's a little bit of a dice this
curses and commentary before we begin
let's actually jump into the paragraph
he talks about uh the spirit of the
revealed religion the Geist right of the
revealed religion has not yet surmounted
its Consciousness as such and it's
interesting because there's two
different words that are getting used in
here two different terms for a process
of transcending right there is
surmounting and that translates
ubervinden or Uber vindung right the
verb or the sort of uh noun
corresponding to that process that's not
the same thing as super session auf
Haven right but there's in both cases a
transcending that is going on
so he says that uh the spirit of
revealed religion has not yet surmounted
its Consciousness as such or what is the
same and here's what we have written up
here it's actual self-consciousness the
self-consciousness that it is the person
that it is is not the object of its
Consciousness something else is the
object the geagenstad of its
Consciousness and so it's kind of
missing itself it may be misrepresenting
itself it may be uh repressing what it
is it may be abstracting away or
substituting some narrative as people do
in revealed religion you know thinking I
am like one of the Apostles no no you're
existing in the 21st century you're not
an apostle that was back then right uh
take stock of who you are today in the
present or in hegel's present of course
the beginning of the 19th century so
he goes on and he says
uh spirit itself as a whole and the
self-differentiated moments within it
fall now he's talking about revealed
religion once again within the sphere of
picture thinking and we've talked a lot
about this picture thinking
for Stalin uh and it could be rep you
know representation it could even be
translated as imagination right we saw
that back in the religion section so we
saw that we we don't want to completely
get rid of picture thinking you know
narratives stories ideas
but we don't want to remain entirely
dependent on it we want to move towards
conceptual or notional thought right but
Griffin and because uh thought so what
we've got here is on the one side
picture thinking and then he talks about
the form of objectivity gagan Stanley
kite right being in the form of an
object
and so this is what picture thinking is
doing and he says the content
of this picture thinking is absolute
Spirit the in halt what it is that it's
got there
but we're not yet at the point where the
form corresponds to the content and we
want to put it in the form
of something greater than that something
that is going to do justice to Absolute
spirit so he says all that now remains
to be done is to supersede of heaven
right this mere form or rather now this
is kind of an interesting phrase rather
since this belongs to Consciousness as
such what belongs to Consciousness is
such
its truth must have already yielded
itself
in the shape of Consciousness truth
variety what we've been searching for
this entire time what we've been
grasping partially seeing that something
is true but not completely true and
trying to we're trying to get to a place
where it's more true
and the truth is going to be there in a
shape Gestalt of Consciousness so the
the previous things that we've been
looking at very important right and we
want to move to a new Shape Of
Consciousness now and that shape of
Consciousness is called absolute knowing
right and it's not just going to be by
the way I should signal this ahead of
time it's not just going to be me as the
philosopher or you as the philosopher or
you know us sort of like you know Hegel
we're not worthy of you worshiping at
the idol of Hegel
it's supposed to be a community I mean
that was part of what we achieved in the
previous stage realizing that the
individual has its meaning its thought
its activity within the scope of a
community of others who are related to
it in terms of something that has been a
desire since the beginning of the
self-consciousness section recognition
or acknowledgment right all right back
to the text so he says
um
truth must already have yielded itself
in the shape of Consciousness this
surmounting of the object
of Consciousness the geagenstad is not
to be taken one-sidedly whenever Hagel
brings up one-sidedness you know there's
that's not good from his perspective it
means that there's something true and
something false involved there right so
he goes on and he says we don't want to
take this one-sidedly
uh to mean that the object showed itself
as returning to the self
but it's to be taken more specifically
to mean not only that the object has
presented itself to the self as
Vanishing for schfinden right what does
it mean Vanishing does it like does that
mean like literally it shows up and sort
of like playing whack-a-mole you're like
there it is and then Boop it goes back
out in its hole you're like where'd it
go and then it pops up again over here
no no it means that what you're getting
is
we might say phenomenologically only
part of the
the object there's other parts that are
not being given to us and as we turn our
attention from one side to the other as
we get to what we're talking about later
on right the totality of individual
determinations
um we were not able to take it all in
and this is you know normal perception
right also with objects of thought or
other other kinds of things that we
could talk about so he goes on and he
says
um it's rather that it is the
externalization of self-consciousness
right so we have the self and the self
here is self-consciousness
um it engages in externalization a word
that we've seen used a lot in the
previous section before crossing the
threshold into absolute knowing and
um it's interesting because Pinker
translates translates this as
self-emptying usually pinkered I've
found is a little bit better than Miller
the text that we've been using this
entire time but I think externalization
is actually closer to the the raw
meaning of this it goes outside of
itself it it you know you could call
itself emptying if you mean that the
self that's here when it locates other
parts of itself outside of itself it
does become empty in those right it
becomes vulnerable is another way of
thinking about it in its actuality in
its activity it's humming actual so it
externalizes itself right and in doing
so what is it doing so he says that it
um
posits literally just sets
you know puts down the thing Hood
the ding height notice a difference in
terminology here so
thing height ding hide thing hood
is not exactly the same thing as
objectivity or object-ness
gagan shendley kite right or I'm
gegenstein zein or being an object thing
an object or not precisely the same but
there's a lot of overlap there right so
there's kind of a nice complementarity
going on here posits the thing hood and
here Miller brackets of the object and
because that's not there directly in the
German uh the thing hood of uh Das Elba
right which could be the object uh makes
sense to say that right so the
self-consciousness
externalizes itself posits the object
the object is showing itself to the
self-consciousness but the
self-consciousness is always also doing
something with the object in relation to
the object and so then he goes on and he
says that
this externalization has two meanings at
least two meanings here right not merely
a negative but also a positive meaning
you know reference you could also say if
you want to a meaning which is and now
we can say here's some differentiation
not merely for us or in itself we could
say well that's the the negative meaning
that we're getting here and notice that
it isn't safe for itself right away for
us
you might say well
why does he differentiating us apart
from the self-consciousness when that
self-consciousness I mean this is where
we're supposed to be isn't isn't this
where we are and and where Hegel is
himself this is the culmination of the
whole phenomenological project that is
the phenomenology of spirit
well there's still a non-coincidence
between self-consciousness even actual
self-consciousness as such and our
self-consciousness right and then it's
we've also got the in itself right that
would be negative and what would be the
positive well the 4 itself uh for fur s
zelst right
um which is a kind of
interesting way of expressing the the
for itself right there so we go on and
you know so we've got a negative and
positive meaning
the negative of the object he says or
itself super session so now here again
we get that auf Haven right that's so
important to the hegelian dialectic but
it's not just uh something being
sublated it is something sublating its
very own self
um cell super session doesn't quite
capture the Zeke zelps alphaben its very
own self right
um so that's the negative and this
passes over into something
positive a positive attitude towards
not negativity as such anymore but
nothingness or
being nothing so he goes in and he says
um
self-consciousness knows the nothingness
of the object
right uh advice is is knowing there
listen so you know makes sense with the
absolute knowing
um knows the nictig kite
of the object
and again here with Das Elba
um of that thing
so it knows now when it's saying it
knows the nothingness of the object is
it saying it knows the object as nothing
no but there is a nothingness within the
object a negativity as there is in
everything right
so he goes on and he says knows the
nothingness of the object on the one
hand because it externalizes its own
self so in externalizing itself it knows
this uh uh nothingness of the object why
because in this externalization it
posits no longer just the object
itself as object or the object as itself
in virtue of the indivisible Unity of
being for self being for self is often
framed as you know kind of in some way
being lesser than being in itself or
being for others or stuff like that in
this case we're getting something really
important here the the for itself is
encompassing the uh in itself the for us
for others right and so
self-consciousness posits itself as an
object an object that also has
nothingness within it same as the other
objects that it's engaged in then he
says on the other hand this positing at
the same time contains the other moment
so you know we've got a duplication here
as well and what is that that
self-consciousness has equally
superseded Alpha Haven right now again
superseded what the externalization and
objectivity to
so its own externalization
culminates in the super session of its
own externalization right
externalization isn't as simple as it
first seemed and it's also superseding
this
objectivity Gangnam Style kite doesn't
mean that the objects go away doesn't
mean that the self isn't an object for
itself
but it's grasping it more once again
can this be done through picture
thinking it can't be done through
picture thinking it can be pictured
through a picture thing it represented
but that representation always falls
short of the activity of thinking and
working your way to this what is being
given to us here this is not for Stellar
this is thought this is concept Concepts
you might say in the plural
so he goes on and he says
um
self-consciousness is equally superseded
this and taken it back into itself now
this communion with itself that's that's
a sort of additional uh word that Hegel
doesn't say it's just with itself right
but Miller put that in there but it is
with in uh it is with itself in its
otherness as such it is other to itself
it is also how it is itself and he goes
on to say this is
the movement of consciousness and in
that movement Consciousness is the
totality of its moment it's a very
important word here we're getting to the
point of wanting to grasp the totality
so all of this stuff
is what is you know being generated as
mental activity you could say and then
coming back to self-consciousness in
this movement and here we get to the end
of this paragraph right
so he says equally Consciousness must
have related itself to the object in
accordance with the totality of the
ladders determinations
and thus grasped it from the standpoint
of each of them and that can be grasped
in terms of a Gestalt of Consciousness
it can be grasped in terms of like you
know the thing in its properties which
is one of the earlier stages how it is
in uh you know force in the
understanding in terms of being part of
a larger Matrix it can be grasping
yourself in terms of the
self-consciousness section are you the
unhappy Consciousness are you retreating
into what Hegel you know mistakenly
construes is stoicism or skepticism we
could go on and on and on right and he's
going to in the following paragraph So
he tells us this totality of its
determinations
establishes the object the gagenstrand
as an implicitly spiritual being so a
spiritual being that is spiritual but
has to have that implicitness drawn out
of it that on Zeke kite we could say or
on zigzign right and it does truly he
says become a spiritual being for
Consciousness when each of its
individual determinations is grasped as
a determination of the self
the self that is conscious of them and
this could be being conscious of you
know objects this could be being
conscious of social processes this could
be being conscious of where I fit into
all of this all of those can be uh you
know gig enstenden for for Consciousness
and so he says Grant they're grasped as
a determination of the self or through
the spiritual relationship to them that
was just mentioned what is the spiritual
relationship to them all of this stuff
right so we're going to have this
important externalization going on we're
moving now past revealed religion and
the representation that it made possible
for us and now we're going to be able to
look back in a new way on all the
terrain which we as phenomenologists
following along with Hegel as a
phenomenologist thinking about the
development of Consciousness through
history and that means through you know
individual Consciousness is relating to
each other through economic processes
through culture through science through
and we could go on and on and on right
and also through conflict because that's
driving the dialectic we are now able to
like look back at that and appreciate it
as a whole but also in each of the
determinations of each of these previous
stages and then we can figure out what
the hell we're doing here and part of
the answer to that is well we're looking
at this stuff and thinking about where
do we go following that